[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing dumbledore
voldemort and the elder wand more
specifically
we're going to be discussing a popular
fan theory which suggests
that dumbledore was never the true owner
of the elder wand
the elder wand was the first halo
created made by death himself
and it was said to be the most powerful
wand that ever existed
the elder wand is made of elder wood and
its core is the tail hair of a thestral
it's 15 inches long and has carvings
down its length
that resemble clusters of elderberries
with the elder wand witches and wizards
have historically been able to produce
intensely powerful magic
that others could only dream of some
magic is actually altogether
impossible without the elder wand
including things like
mending other ones we see this powerful
artifact
past hands on numerous occasions
throughout the harry potter story
and its ownership is of utmost
importance to the plot
after all it's the ownership of the
elder wand that eventually allows harry
to defeat voldemort firing his own
killing curse right back at him
but before harry became its owner in his
final showdown with voldemort
the end of the deathly hallows who were
the true owners
conventionally it is believed that
dumbledore was the owner
followed by draco who disarmed
dumbledore followed by harry who
disarmed draco
but one popular fan theory suggests the
dumbledore was never the true owner at
all
so where does that leave us the main
driver behind the theory is
how the wand actually changes ownership
conventionally
it is believed that a witch or wizard
can only become the true master of the
wand
if they best the previous owner but what
does
best mean while it was originally
suggested that
besting a wizard meant defeating them
the harry potter story seemed to suggest
later on that besting can include an act
as simple
as disarming i.e draco with dumbledore
but is that true the theory in question
suggests that disarming is definitely
not
a valid way of obtaining ownership and
that in order to become the true owner
of such a powerful object
you need to take it forcefully
commanding the ones respect
if we trace back the ones history we can
see that dumbledore took the wand from
grindelwald
and if we look at how grindelwald
obtained the wand we can see that he did
so in a cowardly manner
stealing it from miku gugorovich in the
night
gragorovich burst into the room at the
end of the passage and his lantern
illuminated what looked like a workshop
wood shavings and gold gleamed in the
swinging pool of light
and there on the window ledge sat
perched like a giant bird
a young man with golden hair in the
split second that the lantern's light
illuminated him
harry saw the delights upon his handsome
face then the intruder shot a stunning
spell from his wand
and jumped neatly backward out of the
window with a crow of laughter
the theory is this because grindelwald
stole the wand in a cowardly fashion
he was never its true owner and because
dumbledore took the one from grindelwald
who was not his true owner
he himself could not have become the
true owner this means that for years and
years
even though it was not in his possession
miku kukorovic was the true owner of the
elder wand
but if all this is true how did harry
end up becoming the one's
true owner did he well it starts with
voldemort becoming the owner
voldemort who wanted to escape the
unique circumstances regarding his and
harry's ones
ended up tracking down ollivander after
finding him
voldemort tortured and interrogated him
for information pertaining to the elder
wand
to this olivendar reveals that he had
heard a rumor
that mikukovic still had it in his
possession
the prospect of obtaining a the most
powerful one in the world
and b an instrument that could defeat
harry
was extremely intriguing to voldemort
and so he vowed to track down
gregorovich
for months voldemort tracked kokorovich
down even murdering a family that lived
in his former residence along the way
eventually however voldemort does find
grakorovich
and it's at this point that grakorovich
reveals that the wand was stolen from
him
years ago voldemort who did not believe
ended up using legitimacy to infiltrate
his mind
and it was at this point that voldemort
saw the truth a vision of the wand being
stolen from him
years ago into this voldemort then
demands to know who the thief was
something which gragorovich reveals he
never found out
at this point grigorovich who pleaded
with voldemort for mercy
was no longer of any use to him and is
killed by voldemort's killing curse
at this point the theory suggests that
voldemort
without even knowing it had become the
elder one's true owner
this means that grindelwald was never
the true owner after stealing it from
kukorovic
and it also means that dumbledore wasn't
the true owner after defeating
grindelwald
though voldemort became the true owner
by killing grigorovich
the one still wasn't in his possession
he would need to track it down
eventually however he does finally wield
the wand
the only issue is that this fabled
powerful wand
is just not living up to his
expectations he tests it out
time and time again and believes there
is no difference between his ordinary
wand
and this powerful magical artifact he
eventually comes to the conclusion
that it's not a problem with the wand
but a problem with
him yes he now held the elder wand in
his possession
but from his perspective because snape
had killed dumbledore
snape was the true owner not him this
meant that the wand would never work to
its full capabilities
it's not until voldemort finally kills
snape that he becomes completely
satisfied
what the theory suggests here is that
though he was the rightful owner at this
stage the reason he lacked power
was for reasons unrelated to the wand or
the once ownership
voldemort didn't lack power because he
wasn't the true owner
he lacked power because pieces of his
soul were being destroyed
he was the owner of the elder wand now
sure
but many pieces of his soul had been
destroyed without him even realizing it
making him weaker and weaker when harry
scores a victory of a voldemort later in
the story
destroying him it's only at that point
that harry becomes the true owner
this theory is only reinforced by
rowling who seems to suggest
that it takes a great deal for the wand
to properly change allegiance
the elder wand is simply the most
ruthless of ones
in that it will only take into
consideration strength
one would expect a certain amount of
loyalty from once want
so even if you were disarmed while
carrying it even if you lost a fight
while carrying it
it has developed an affinity with you
that it won't give up easily
if however a wand is one properly won in
an adult jewel
then a wand may switch allegiance
however the elder wand knows no loyalty
except to strength it's completely
unsentimental
it will only go where the power is so if
you win
then you've won the wand you don't need
to kill with it
but almost inevitably it attracts
wizards who are prepared to kill
and who will kill and also it attracts
wizards like voldemort
who confuse being prepared to murder
with strength
in essence this theory closes the plot
hole that simply disarming your opponent
counts as besting them what do you guys
think of this theory
had you heard of it before let me know
in the comments section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget
to live
[Music]
you